[Music]
from the Monday morning podcast mr. bill
Bern I feel bad sitting down like I'm
like some [ __ ] piece-of-shit
performer but that's how I do it this is
what this what's that I don't know what
do you mean buddy but half happy to you
- happy Diwali
whatever that mates is that an Asian
thing that couldn't tell us very fast
some sort of accent there
how's global warming working for you
guys in Asia is that a good thing -
shutting off all the [ __ ] lights out
here there's gonna be high winds where
poor people are we don't want them to
burn to death the rich people in the
mansions will be ok I think like
everybody has like conspiracy tips for
those people listening at home or
possibly watching wherever the [ __ ] this
is gonna be wherever this was gonna live
if we could find a safe space on the
Internet by the way you guys shouldn't
have clapped you know somebody from
Oxford might be listening to this nobody
nobody saw this [ __ ] those [ __ ]
idiots over there at Oxford is am I
saying the right thing said a farm
animal is that the expense of school
they said that clapping they banned
clapping you got to do they said jazz
hands but it's like you know when when
deaf people which I've never seen a deaf
person do that why would you do that why
wouldn't you just go like this
yeah nice performance why would you go
ah I got my hands up here I don't think
that's deaf people trolling us is that
the right as deaf is that bad now you
know like [ __ ] you can't say [ __ ]
now can't say deaf can't say
flight-attendant
you know telling you if you go into a
coma when you could when you wake up you
won't be able to speak English anymore
Oh what are you speaking those old words
for a [ __ ] hit me at the car I didn't
hear him who is this guy he's a witch I
was in a coma for 20 [ __ ] years
anyways for those people listening at
home there's some sort of I don't know
what's going on there they're there they
ran out of power out here in this sunny
state they ran out of ways to [ __ ] uh
I guess keep the lights on they're
saying there's gonna be fires or
something like that with like I don't 90
mile an hour [ __ ] winds it's crowds
getting quiet like all that power is
getting shut off it's not funny man now
if you have if you have solar panels on
your on your [ __ ] house does that
mean like everybody else is like living
in like Mad Max time and you still got
your flat screen what bet that by like
90 mile an hour [ __ ] winds people
flying by with their big green eggs and
you're just in the future right just
sitting there with your solar panels not
letting anybody in right like that
[ __ ] Jesus [ __ ] down there in Houston
didn't let any of the fatties in the
whole place was flooded he basically had
an arc right and these people were as
big as oxes and farm animals
he could have reenacted the whole thing
and let these people in and he did
he did not he didn't even put moorings
outside of it cuz maybe he could have
like tied a few fatties up and clung to
him like Leonardo DiCaprio at the end of
[ __ ] let's go say tightrope Titanic
what a terrible [ __ ] movie it just
such a you know do the measure if they
made 9/11 into a chick flick and then
like hundreds of years later you're like
I don't want to [ __ ] see it
[Applause]
Leo's holding the emergency door for the
last person that's gonna make it down
the stairs know that women haters let it
[ __ ] ego oh boy he's got all the
[ __ ] door hain't got a nice [ __ ]
it's unbelievable a bunch of people you
know [ __ ] pissed off people would've
been if they live long enough to [ __ ]
see that hunk of [ __ ] I'm sorry I don't
mean to go do i I don't know who is that
James Cameron said it was he said some
hits I think we'll survive this podcast
he walks there goes DVD sales yeah so
anyways they're happy he's black I don't
why don't we just can convert to solar
power there's a guy down the street he's
got [ __ ] solar power and I just don't
know how to approach this guy you know
cuz I don't know him you know it's weird
like why can't I use a fellow Americans
say I'm envious of what you have on your
roof who put him up there how much did
it cost how do I go about that it can't
just walk up and knock on the door right
maybe as a rescue pit bull in there he's
[ __ ] lets it go you know it's weird
people think just down in the south you
can't just walk up to somebody selves
but out here you know Ellie's [ __ ]
it's a crazy place you know it's all
kinds of phony [ __ ] you know all of
that [ __ ] with the Botox and then also
Yuki it's so easy to get killed out here
you hear the tension in the crowd those
of you at home hey let's go to a
baseball game where's Mike I don't know
oh there he is getting kicked to death
in the parking lot he had the wrong
colored hankerchief oh I had one of the
great [ __ ] old man moments my life
okay so I'm driving driving in the
Comedy Store I feel weird trying to even
look out at you guys like I'm supposed
to be alone this is just like this is
like back in the day when I would stay
it like a super8 they wouldn't have a
couch as nice as this but it wouldn't be
like [ __ ] like long enough so you
could lay down on it so then you'd have
to drag some other [ __ ] piece of
furniture over like this and then stick
your legs up like ah this is better this
is better than sleeping in the bed you
know with John Wayne Gacy had a [ __ ]
threesome with a couple of Oh Phil come
on
not like that don't don't be like that
don't [ __ ] it be like dead alright so
anyway I'm driving down the road I'm not
lying down like this but I'm driving
down the road and I was listening to
audios born yes and I was listening to
some of that Randy Rhoads [ __ ] right
that [ __ ] song say pull up I'm going
to the comedy store and I'm stopped at a
red light on Crescent Heights and Laurel
no that doesn't make sense Crescent
Heights in Sunset and I'm [ __ ]
sitting there there's an open lane next
to me because it merges in this nobody
there and you know I said my windows
down I got it cranked you know like the
old guy that a.m. and all of a sudden
you know we just feel like somebody
looking at you and I [ __ ] look over
and there's a guy like a year or two
older than me on the sidewalk dressed
like he's he whoa he was jocking but
stopped and he's just looking at me and
I'm like what the [ __ ] and he starts
air-drumming
to the song
so I'm like my windows are down I don't
wanna put the window up because he's
close enough that that offends him he's
gonna lunge at me with whatever he's
stuck in his arm and then I have what he
has right so I'm trying to ignore him
and he's just I feel I can just feel the
heat of him and I [ __ ] look over he's
still staring he's still [ __ ]
air-drumming
and then I see he crushes all in the
fills like those 80 fills do know and
he's [ __ ] crushing it while he's just
looking at me at that point I just start
laughing he never breaks character the
light turns green and then
simultaneously we both do the devil
horns and throw away and I was just like
yeah I was like that was [ __ ] awesome
because a few likes earlier I was a
little self-conscious you know it's in a
younger part of Hollywood until probably
look at the old bald man listening to us
you know whatever you guys probably like
Benny Goodman music to you guys right I
actually said Glenn Miller as a
reference to old music and to somebody
in like their late 20s and 30s they go
who's that Wow judging by you guys you
don't know who the [ __ ] that is either
and I realized that my music is
basically I guess it's that I don't I
can't believe that it is but anyway
thank that happened that was that was a
fun one you know to bond with somebody
like that you know I wish I could have
talked to me like I saw I saw him in
Oakland it's look 79 I was there when he
bit the bats [ __ ] head off I'm the
one who threw it right you know what a
juxtaposition that isn't on the way down
here I was listening to Sirius satellite
radio and I was listening to I like old
country I don't know why I just like it
you know I think it has to do with
everybody yelling at each other now
about politics it's just there's
something about it it's just [ __ ]
quiet it makes you feel like you got
your own spread out on a [ __ ] lake or
something
and I just like but I cannot get past
how much they kiss their [ __ ] crowds
ass those this is this grand ole Opry's
so we're just so happy to be here you
guys just you know I mean you can sing
along you're probably know the words
better than me it's like do you know all
the words you sing this song every
[ __ ] night it's why you drink alright
stop and the crowds just eating it up
but Lulu mercy you just you know I mean
I can't believe if y'all came out to see
me here tonight
you're at the Grand Ole Opry you're a
[ __ ] star okay
so he went to an open mic and all of a
sudden what I'm famous these [ __ ]
people
just eat it up they eat it up cuz they
[ __ ] it this selfish comedy country
crowds are [ __ ] selfish that's all it
is
now that the selfish [ __ ] people and
they need the [ __ ] guy on stage a
woman on stage right or they on stage to
constantly see covered all my bases
shimmering hands shimmering hands they
need to constantly have the performer
bring them down to their level or even
like look just you know I feel like I'm
playing backyard but the family bring
the dead Rick the doctor need to do
right I like to thank Mark shields any
Bravo their name every [ __ ] a guy who
parked my car they [ __ ] thank
everybody it's like reverse Beyonce you
know what I mean Beyonce's up there it's
just like to her whole vibe cuz my
daughter might and and my wife watch
that that that [ __ ] concert all the
goddamn time right and her whole vibe is
like [ __ ] you
you could never be as good as me
flicking her [ __ ] hair it's it's it's
amazing it's amazing that there's a
crowd those people can't get an update
yeah treat me like [ __ ] why am I in the
same structure as you I don't know I
think if those dudes went to a country
[ __ ] thing they'd probably pass out
from like the love that they got from
the person on stage because that seems
to be what they're looking for but a lot
of them are gay it's a country crowd so
they probably get the [ __ ] kicked out of
them something I get it yeah
sometimes you got to talk through it to
figure out why this team it is a great
thing about having a daughter is I
actually know Beyonce songs now you know
she goes get up let's dance let's dance
oh I have to dance to Beyonce don't say
oh it's not cute it's [ __ ]
soul-crushing all right that [ __ ]
homeless jogger saved me anyway I always
went for you underrated underrated not
watching any football on a football
Sunday sacrilegious I did it today I got
so much [ __ ] done it was [ __ ]
ridiculous then all you do is you just
pop in and you watch the [ __ ] ticker
you kind of know what's going on they're
gonna show you all the good plays what's
that
Jesus how hammered second Lorna [ __ ]
who won the [ __ ] tag again dude
you're like there was like the Jackie
Gleason show level drunk
hey you mr. Donaghy who I'm gonna look
it up for you who won them
I might even I might even Google
I might even [ __ ] Google that I know
my [ __ ] password here oh come on BAM
open please open nothing this is not my
laptop that's the [ __ ] problem stops
oh maybe I'm doing the capital letter
maybe I don't need to do that how about
that there it is there it is
spoiler alert you do that and fight the
guy did that at one of those [ __ ]
superhero movies he got the [ __ ] kicked
on it right which by the way don't you
think that guy should have won something
just for doing that ruining a decade of
people watching movies right nine years
nine up nine movies of that superhero
thing that was [ __ ] hilarious how
offended those people got when [ __ ]
Scorsese and all these great directors
were like yeah those movies kind of suck
I mean technically they're movies within
that really movies shut up shut up
you're [ __ ] Batman and Robin I know
the joke I gotta see the joke joke
movies are great which some of them are
[ __ ] great and then other ones that
just like I went to that that Batman
Superman one just had my fingers in my
ear for like [ __ ] three hours it was
like louder than ac/dc like Jesus Christ
these two guys just [ __ ] each other
already all this rolling her how many
[ __ ] skyscrapers have to collapse
before they just admit their love and
respect for one another go back to his
[ __ ] theater as solitude whatever the
[ __ ] you call it
all right wait a second ah my pick of
the day didn't happen well I don't know
what this spread was what was this
spread in the Seattle Seahawks Falcons
game
oh is it even why was it no spread I
don't get that Pete Carroll's sneaky
pete [ __ ] uh he [ __ ] loses to the
[ __ ] Ravens and all of a sudden this
then they play the hapless Falcons I
don't [ __ ] get that there's no spread
I don't buy that I'm not buying that
doesn't gonna sports talk show I'm not
but I'm wait for the Patriots to lose
and then every on ESPN just be like will
the New England Patriots exposed today
it's now is it all it's all the way over
here and now is it all the way over here
is anybody still watching they played
nobody
they played [ __ ] nobody and then you
wait now next week it starts you play
Ravens with their running back
quarterback right guy runs all over the
pho many times they're gonna sell me
that [ __ ] guy this guy will do
everything for us all over the fair and
then he gets hit then he can't run and
now he's got a pass now he's [ __ ] you
don't need to do that as a quarterback
look at Tom Brady the guy can barely
[ __ ] walk it's unbelievable but he
knows where to look and he's [ __ ]
frozen - that's it run and all what are
you doing that's other people's jobs
it's like you're the manager of an
Applebee's and you're bussing tables
what are you doing greet the customers
get him to this seats you keep the
[ __ ] thing running I would tell you
guys I used to [ __ ] I used to work in a
restaurant way back in the day that was
that was going out of business is one of
these things they put like a five-star
restaurant in an area where people had
like you know I don't know two-star
brains so I don't know what they were
trying to elevate the entire area like
it was a five-star like this is like the
80s five-star restaurant right next to
like a record town you know people like
me is a new ac/dc yeah and they got like
some lobster soufflé next door so
needless to say this [ __ ] was tanking
right so three people dumped like a ton
of money into it
another guy he just Peters had the
equipment from another failed restaurant
they got a business with a guy like yeah
I [ __ ] this up before well come on in
we gotta get in business with you this
guy knows Hana not succeed in this
business so he had all the [ __ ]
restaurant equipment so he came in right
and I don't get anybody in trouble here
let's just say there was people [ __ ]
dipping in the register there was [ __ ]
Bannon and banette and there was a lot
of Eric Clapton songs being played in
the back I don't remember the [ __ ]
point of this but Nauticus continued to
tell the stories all right here's one
for you
Oh easy right now this is a big time
right now for women right it's a big
time for me yeah big time
right I don't know why you to do the
Joan Jett chick in your leg out I don't
know what the problem is I don't know
what it is but I know uh white women do
not feel appreciated anytime here women
bitching nine times out of ten on
television it's gonna be a white woman I
don't get it it's like you're [ __ ]
white [ __ ] white what is the problem
anyway you have no idea it's just so
difficult to be a white lady in America
do you have any idea what it's like to
not be pulled over because of the color
of your skin
do you have any idea what it's like to
marry a toxic white male and then take
him for everything he's got three years
later didn't still feel that toxicity in
the pool you didn't pay for
I have no sympathy for white women I
don't
I hope they I hope they get what's
coming to him
so I don't mean any [ __ ] I'm just
hedging my bets okay
in case I'm yet another person in the
public eye who gets so full of
themselves that someday decides to run
for president you don't celebrities do
that right now are you gonna ride you
had a couple of successful movies do you
plan on trying to run the free world
I've won every fight in my movies why
can't I win it real life so I just say
outrageous [ __ ] so that that'll stop me
someday when I just go yeah I'm gonna
[ __ ] run for president then they'll
just pull up a clip of me doing this I
think white women go extinct to whatever
the [ __ ] I just said do you think you've
lost touch with the female voters my my
favorite [ __ ] thing I like Trump
supporters me like I liked rummy
give a [ __ ] it's my favorite given well
I probably should give a [ __ ] I mean
he's a lot of things you should give a
[ __ ] about doesn't give a [ __ ] that's
how I live my life I don't give a [ __ ] I
just feel something I [ __ ] do it I
fake it I [ __ ] say it
I let the chips fall where they may I
like the president that runs the White
House the way I run my lap that's what I
like I can relate to it putting out
fires all over my trailer
that's such a bad stereotype of a trump
supporter there's a lot of people to
protecting their money you know you got
to have a [ __ ] you know it's a deal
you get money you gotta you got to go
for the [ __ ] the the rich white dude
who's grabbing a [ __ ] so I mean that's
just how it works
do you want to hang on to your blood
money you need a blood money guy in the
in the White House I don't like the
glorification of not giving a [ __ ] by
the way that's one of the easiest things
not caring that's easy what do you thing
about that I don't give a [ __ ] it's easy
what do you thing about that I mean I
think it's a major problem and I took
you know it's like global warming if you
actually have the [ __ ] balls to read
data on that [ __ ] I mean you're better
than I am
I know go into I don't give a [ __ ] I
just look I just look at it like you
know there's something in that room I
don't want to deal with and I just sit
there slowly rocking they're gonna
figure it out they're gonna figure it
out I'll just do what they tell me to do
and maybe that'll work I don't know you
know I like about this election though
it doesn't seem to be any women running
which is great you know what I mean
let's get him back
nothing I'm against a woman president I
just hate the excitement just because
she's a woman
I just [ __ ] in oh my god she doesn't
have a tallywacker which they're all
gonna end up on that [ __ ] tour all
right the blood money tour they go on to
give speeches to the [ __ ] people that
they hadn't worked for when they were
there right your boys they're hot
[ __ ] Hollywood Obama he's out there
doing that [ __ ] isn't he ran out there
thousand points of light talking all
those [ __ ] bankers they don't give a
[ __ ] right that's sitting there eating a
deep-fried eagle cuz he's talking
I mean they like those two a ridiculous
the way they vacuuming up the [ __ ]
money she's on [ __ ] Tori longer I
wonder if one of his kids gets a drone
at like Radio Shack or something if he
has like flashbacks but he gave good
speeches um I don't know why I just get
all that [ __ ] Jaguars won with that
dude with the porn stache I like that
guy you know makes me feel like I'm
watching an old Burt Reynolds movie you
know taste it you pull tab [ __ ] beer
all right Redskins lose again Vikings
win Seattle wins Bears lost by one
[ __ ] point they just can't do a chart
you got it by the way if you live out
here in LA if you're a football fan you
got to go to a charger game that [ __ ]
stadium and it's like seeing a football
game in the 1940s there's like 15,000
people aren't they are two Chargers
playing the Chiefs in like Mexico City
ah that's because I want to see Pat
Ramones at little last [ __ ] Stadium
it's like he's playing here think he's
right [ __ ] there
I could hear I'm calling the place in
the bottle
hey you gotta go there everybody else
said own everybody got the brand new
stadiums Lions hang on to bait the
Giants what else what else happened
today anything surprising Jesus Christ
Drew Brees is back 31 10 9 what else
this is what you know what's great about
through the live podcast is I realized
when you guys start to drift off and
almost hit a telephone pole
what do you don't give a [ __ ] about what
I'm talking about Patriots would again
is this the greatest bait really matter
they played the Jets twice the Dolphins
the Redskins the Browns it's like the
end of a keg and you're just trying to
get one more [ __ ] it's just all suds
trying to get drunk off of it our season
starts next week
with the Ravens then we got the Chiefs
and I'm hoping Patrick mahomes is gonna
be healthy you know you want the
superstars to be healthy so you can feel
good about the victory that you had
nothing to do with right I had nothing
to do with that and I just want to say
all right what else anybody watch the
formula 1 today
anybody jesus [ __ ] christ Lewis
Hamilton how many you know I root
against then the way root for alum root
against Alabama just because I got into
it so late and he was the best guy and
it's just like it's not that personal
I just root against to the guy but I it
gets ridiculous like my hate to say this
but my wife four kids were with the in
or in earshot right upstairs and the
best part of the race is the start when
Lewis isn't in first place because if
he's in first place how [ __ ] good he
is he has pole position in his team he
once he if he's in first place in the
first turn the [ __ ] race is over and
then you're just sitting after 70 laps
okay who's gonna come in second third
who gives a [ __ ] right when he's in like
third place he's he's like upset hey
it's all [ __ ] mad so you know he's
gonna do some crazy [ __ ]
within reason so the [ __ ] race starts
and they're taking off and I'm and I'm
so hoping that both Ferraris are in
first place you know first a second and
then [ __ ] tearing through the turn
and I don't know what happened all this
[ __ ] commotion and
of a sudden he's off the [ __ ] track
he comes flying back and I'm like
finally he's gonna have some [ __ ]
Daniel Ricciardo bad [ __ ] luck now he
comes right back on the [ __ ] track
and the whole time the whole first four
turns I am off the couch the way I
haven't been for most NFL games this
year for whatever [ __ ] reason I'm off
the couch am i you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] now now you [ __ ] cut
[Music]
it's I'm building the guys luck
it can't be luck he's got to be that
good he [ __ ] bangs into another guy's
car the other guy he gets a [ __ ] flat
he [ __ ] hit some busload of kids he's
just like [ __ ] he just keeps going I
have damage under the rear of my car it
just top so anyway so I guess because of
the altitude whatever some [ __ ]
everybody has the wrong [ __ ] tires on
on is that the right words they're
wearing the wrong tires so they're
chewing him up or whatever and Ferrari
goes okay well don't try to get too far
in front of them cuz we're gonna try to
do a one-stop strategy or whatever
meanwhile Daniel Cardos in the back he's
on a hard compound and he's tearing up
the [ __ ] field so Mercedes sees that
takes in that information they have
[ __ ] Lewis Hamilton pin early and
they're like what the [ __ ] Ferrari stays
out there and then he has the hard tyres
he just [ __ ] runs them down the guy
whence the [ __ ] racist
unbeliev [ __ ] time I think Ferrari
that's just why do i watch why do i
watch
I've given up like I've tried to not get
into this mindset as a sports fan like
maybe I hope we can watch auto racing
and I won't be leaping up and down guard
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm still
doing it I'm yelling at cars
it's time to stop blaming the events
bill it's you right
my wife has such a funny thing she does
when I say inappropriate stuff she just
says my name really loud really tersely
she just goes back cuz nothing really
needs to be sent
she just needs to snap me out of it she
doesn't need to say hey you should be
yelling [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] jumping
up and down in the living room screaming
at cars probably gave my kid a complex
if I were taking a go see that [ __ ]
Pixar movie right see those little
cartoon cars that's what Dad does say
that's what that that's say so
congratulations the Lewis Hamilton
Mercedes I guess they're they're just
they're just better
I don't know why I don't know why I keep
watching so anyways there's that how
many I don't know what time how many
minutes have I done in there I don't
know when I'm supposed to start reading
advertising did anybody the Packer
spoiler - yeah actually you're done 18
minutes at 30 seconds just too late at
all did he pass out already here
oh my god I just figured out this whole
[ __ ] day he just drank all day I'm
gonna [ __ ] sue them give you the plan
we're gonna go to the ten o'clock start
cricket one o'clock and then we'll go
see bills pocket what's that
no no please
I love this he sounds like a like a
warped record that a 45 a 33 it's all
speed you're my Packers we're in this
cut this should be like an ESPN 9 and
it's just this guy whenever you either
watch them passed out or just like a
bragger you great trade rumor today Las
Vegas what were you trying to say sir
[Laughter]
that's that's a beer drunk
that is a beer drunk that's not that's
not liquor liquor he'd be getting
violent beer just kind of ah I don't
want to say I love you guys you guys are
great
that's all right sir just stockpile
those ideas will happen you can just say
all of them in the end all at the same
[ __ ] time what about the charger game
yes I did feels like hours ago when I
said that Oh pack isn't today plate
yeah well you have any I'm trying to say
what you're saying we're saying the same
thing here sir all right there we go
okay okay enough participation that's
all right please don't shush like I have
anything to say up here I've yelled
can't like 15 times I Shh what's what
horrible thing is he gonna say next
oh here it is
drug addicts let's talk about drug
addicts you know I was saying I was at
the grocery store you know cuz I have
nothing better to do on a Sunday then go
down and [ __ ] buy [ __ ] that I forgot
to buy the last time I was there and I
get up to the register yeah I know it's
funny actually went in to buy vitamins
and for some reason I went to where the
spices are I was pointing at the cuz
they look the same it's the same shaped
[ __ ] vial they're always green you
know so there's a guy stockpiling like
spices and I was like do you know what
vitamin b6 and something else my wife
wanted or something in the guys I'm
pointing at it and he's just looking
like
cuz no no that's all away it's aisle 14
it's all the way on the it's one of
those those nice grocery stores will
they actually walk with you the whole
[ __ ] way you know what I mean like
come this way and it gets like weird if
it's too long like I this is I'm running
on a [ __ ] to talk about
just I understand how the numbers in the
alphabet work just [ __ ] tell me one
two three four five aids on the Left
bees on the right but I was such a Moore
and he didn't even walk with me he was
just like yeah it's all the way it's
over there buddy try not to kill
yourself on the one of the [ __ ] way
over there so anyway I'm in there and I
go up to the goddamn register and there
was some impatient guy white dude with
like it's like brown dreads that went
into blonde dreads and his wife showed
up with two big things a toilet paper
and she was real mousy you know what I
mean like a guy like that needs a mousie
chick who won't stand up for herself no
you don't that's how it is ladies that's
why you need to be brave and ferocious
whatever you're calling yourselves on
the inner you need to be that way or
else you end up like with a guy like
this cuz a guy like that need somebody
like that's the only way a relationships
gonna work get our enemy no all right
well I saw today and it was working the
relationship was working she came
walking up with this two things big
things at toilet papers you say hey look
sooner he goes now she just watch it and
she just walked away he yelled at her
right in front of me and she took it she
took it so you know what I say she
deserves that relationship
nobody deserves that relationship what I
was trying to show was how cold and
heartless society could be in a
supermarket when we're too concerned
with checking out rather than the safety
of our women listen if she had any heart
she would have dumped the toilet paper
gone back and got some tuna cans and
then they and we went now then she
couldn't she had a blunt object she
could then she could then beat him
anyway so I'm staying in there why this
shit's going I was like I don't want to
I don't want to be here when this you
know when the end of this relationship
happens so I went another I don't need
to be sequestered sir were you close
enough budget him with that frozen
KitKat um hey is anybody by the way
anybody live on a [ __ ] Street out
here where like you don't know if kids
are gonna show up for Halloween and
that's such an unsettling feeling it's
like do I roll the dice and have no
[ __ ] candy and have these
[ __ ] do what me and my friends
used to do two people had no candy at
their house or or do I buy all this
candy okay buy all the viola can yeah
but then you stuck with the candy and
then what are you gonna do you're gonna
start eating it then you start to like
it then you start you start you know
leaning to one side uh you know you guys
don't live on your own your parents
aren't here anymore to be like hey
you've had enough of those right is
there anything scarier as an adult to go
then than going out and buying a whole
bag of [ __ ] candy and having one of
those old lady bulls those glass balls
and just pouring it in there and just
having it right there
that right there that candy your hand in
your mouth is the recipe to someday
having to be cut out of your house
that's how it starts you just have [ __ ]
you shouldn't be eating just that like
as dangerous as that is that it's us
sound awesome you know like if you just
didn't give a [ __ ] and then you gotta
have like one of those old lady like
Ottomans right and you have just your
feet you have your feet up you [ __ ]
recliner right why would you have an
ottoman if you have a recliner you know
maybe you have giantism you know enemy
and you're only seven you sold in the
recliner you're already throwing it
right pretty soon you'll be able to
change the channels with your toes you
know there's one group of people you can
still make fun of you know they don't
seem to have a strong presence on the
internet you know it is their fingers
are too big for the keyboards they're
there silently naked they can they can
use a mouse but they can't type their
feelings via giantism I would just roll
with it I would just have somebody make
me like like a big like furry like
onesie that just goes over one shoulder
like like sergeant slaughter used to
have and then I would just go to malls
and I would just just walk through
everybody's gonna walk into the food
court if you're I just see if I could
scare anybody um I'll get some emails on
that one you know
[Music]
you know what I actually you know I
watch a lot of car shows where they they
they redo cars and everything there's
one that they could do you know there's
got to be somebody out there listening
right now who has giantism and as a car
guy but there's just no car form so you
just ask him what his car is and then
they modify it so he can fit in it right
he's like no you just get like a
Winnebago and you tear out the first
three quarters of it and in the back
where they lay down you just turn that
into the seat all right and then you
just do do what they out you know you
raise the roof a little bit and then you
just do what they always do you drop it
down get some big old [ __ ] breaks you
know change the lines on it right no
you're not seeing that giant Hurst
shifter made out of a [ __ ] fishbowl
at him somebody's crutches right anyway
hey how soon before they start selling
pills like cyanide pills just to have in
your house if it's like if whatever's
gonna happen in the next 30 years the
collapse of the dollar two and a half
two hundred mile per hour firestorm you
don't feel like going out like that you
know
just one of those you look out the
window and everybody's on fires a zombie
leg [ __ ] it just it's the easy way out
you know what I mean what do you say to
God after that you know just be like
what was I supposed to do is they
supposed to [ __ ] burn to die me I
mean I ended the last 18 seconds of my
life other than that I didn't commit
suicide I was gonna be dead like 30
seconds I wouldn't I miss out on what
kind of God are you isola take that
[ __ ] I didn't take that swig of Drano
that was no picnic maybe you still let
you in but you got it you got to go in
after all this smoked up people you know
your neighbors all crispy going you
should have hung in there me I would
rather take 30 seconds of flames then an
entire eternity whatever the [ __ ] they
say the math doesn't even work out on
that you know to me once you get used to
burning after a while huh you know much
I would love to do that bit in front of
that guy I listen to it the Grand Ole
Opry I'm just so happy y'all came out
and then I just [ __ ] come out there
just be like you know what you get used
to Hellfire after a while
this guy is the devil I used to know a
guy with giantism and always see him
come I used to love watching drink
moonshine he can [ __ ] do it like a
shot glass you just suck that [ __ ]
down that's it
I actually was in South Carolina South
Carolina and people try to shush up
their [ __ ] state let it come with an
edge town you over here sip a dip in
Seattle stop trying to make your [ __ ]
city sound cool if it's cool people will
know they're not gonna go there
[Laughter]
Albuquerque's that's a cool place
anybody watched El Camino yet yeah shut
up Green Bay guy don't say well actually
uh Jesse [ __ ] start to tornado
I watched yeah I was [ __ ] amazing
it's [ __ ] amazing
once again Vince Gilligan and the whole
crew [ __ ] crush it again and I also
watched for the first time ever I
watched Chinatown any script writers
here that's the one they always tell you
this was this was a perfect script it
was an absolutely
perfect script from the opening shot
page ten we understand what the
protagonist is doing to the antagonist
spits into act one twenty three point
two pages I actually watched it and I
absolutely loved it and it was just a
[ __ ] you know you want to talk about
not a Hollywood ending watch that movie
underrated because I feel like you guys
it's kind of slipping away like
considering like I think like bands that
I list like Aussies probably on oldies
now you know I can't imagine it's like
Chinatown like a [ __ ] Laurel and
Hardy movie to you guys at this why are
fat woman's so good at piano nobody
knows you know it is they saw the keys
they thought it was lady fingers to a
cheesecake and they really reached out
to him and then they fall in love with
the song what they have food issues
always had those blue veiny legs you
know that housecoat what they did just
too much weight on the legs you know
things burst and we are here tonight to
raise money for all the old brave
warrior fat women that play piano oh I
gotta look this up someone was trying to
tell me this I can't believe it's true
so I'm gonna go on the internet to find
if it's true it up cuz the internet
never lies yeah somebody's trying to
claim that China is starting all these
fires I mean Jesus cry make it wait he
wouldn't even come up with that like
well I want to do those drugs alright
Massachusetts juice its word [ __ ]
about that ban to ban the b-word all
right this is this in Massachusetts is
actually a bizza bill I know it's
unbelievable you can you and anyone else
can file legislation in Malky about the
bill to ban the b-word okay there was
just somebody who filed the legislation
I guess Massachusetts House this week
approved a bill to pump an extra 1.5
billion
oh wait a minute that's be into
publication education over the next day
that's not the B word that got a lot of
media attention
yeah don't talk about smart stuff get to
the fun stuff
House bill three seven one-niner that
generated the most buzz yet another B
word it was why is this guy trying to be
so [ __ ] clever just say what happens
also this isn't a thing this is the case
they're going to try to like ban the B
word like a [ __ ] if you say the word
[ __ ]
then then you'd go to jail or something
in Massachusetts which you know hey
listen Massachusetts is racist and
they're sick of these rappers selling
all these [ __ ] albums so they're
trying to get them in jail this is
clearly pointed at one particular race
of people
this word is really not in the white
community other than like people who
watched like Dwight people watch a lot
of reality TV they start to get the head
going get up there like cul-de-sac
ghetto so sis you know like when you go
to restaurants is Asian infused Italian
this is you know they're doing that with
like race you haven't noticed
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's not the lack of laughter it's this
it's the pretending not to know that's
what kills me that is what's gonna
slowly kill me as someone who does what
the [ __ ] I did they just I don't even
notice
I am so progressive that I don't notice
what everybody else notice yeah most of
them will end up in a trunk of a car at
some point because they're gonna feel
like this person's a serial killer but
they don't want to offend and they want
to be an ally
well yes I will help you get that spare
out creepy person all right is this even
a podcast anymore my just Philip Oh drug
addicts that was my point so I go up to
the register let's go back there's the
[ __ ] there's this the [ __ ] white
dude with the blonde dreads with the
mousy woman they both deserve each other
he's not a nice guy so he's not gonna
get a strong woman right he's gonna get
a mouthy person like they tell me with
an axe behind you right then his [ __ ]
head hacked off oh my god I just
pictured that guy with his dreads bangin
a mousy woman think that's got to be the
most
awful sexual experience ever just are
you enjoying this yeah if you enjoy I
enjoy forget it that's probably a
website mousy woman's sex they know what
they want but they won't say it can't
one man with a progressive dick get her
to come out of her sexual shell this
will be a weird time to do ad reads do I
have ad what do I have every no reach
smart man smart man smart how far into
this and resemble us everybody the guy
who is behind them the man behind the
music Wow look at this dynasty
typewriter here we got some three guts
there you go these are some of the
questions how much time have I done i
I've done 40 minutes I've done 40
minutes okay all right cool all right
cool Jesus Christ the drug aunt thing I
have not you know what how much does it
annoy you guys when I do the podcast and
I never get back to the thing you like
[ __ ] you left me hang it that has to be
that has to be a new segment called Bill
never finished now I will do that okay
Jesus Christ I felt like Thanksgiving
dinner like wait do you guys also think
I do that yes yes we do you're the
[ __ ] we were kind of hoping you
wouldn't show up just Bobby ate it was
it weren't even mean bla ba ting huh
means me undies okay um the drug addict
I will finish this one so I'm standing
line trying to get away from the the
loud mousy [ __ ] you know yin and yang
of [ __ ] awful people you wouldn't
want to drive across the country with
huh isn't that beautiful
or like it's the Grand Canyon you miss
everything so I look and on one of these
magazine covers is yet another [ __ ]
famous person who was on drugs and now
they're off of drugs and then it's just
you know it's I just cannot stand the
person that interviews them you know
they sit there all fascinated you did
wait the guy's I mean I was up to like I
was doing nine thousand dollars worth of
cocaine a day nine thousand I mean how
did you even manage you know they just
sit there like fascinated like they're
the first person to juggle like 1990s in
the air like how did you get to that
[ __ ] level I just wished one time
someone would just not be sympathetic
well that's an incredible waste of money
what the [ __ ] would you do that for they
have an idea how selfish that is to
everyone that knows and loves you 9
grand worth of coke how much [ __ ]
money do you have you [ __ ] you know
this homeless people know I excite I
don't you know you know what I say I say
let him be no I don't I don't help him
out but like enough with the [ __ ]
just sitting across the room like you
know and then I started doing crystal
meth so how did that work out huh she
didn't see the billboards you know bill
it's not as simple is that um alright
here we go
the pumpkin patch moms oh I was talking
about this last week when I went to a
pumpkin patch with my kid thinking I was
literally doing some Norman Rockwell
stuff and I show up and there was all
these hoary moms with their butt cheeks
and their titties hanging out like their
husband wasn't like I don't know what
was going on you know
you're married it's over it's done
you've gone to a high school reunion put
your [ __ ] away
there's kids here Jacob you know chess
and affection what she wants to look
like a matinee stripper and a [ __ ]
pumpkin patch I say more power to her
all right I would like to address hey
Billy the Kid I would like to address
your issue issues well I can't tell
which way this is gonna go
we're [ __ ] dressed moms at the pumpkin
patch by the end of the email I hope to
quell your frustrations on the topic or
at least respect the opinion I present
now Jesus oh god I hope to quell your
front come on he's got an ascot on he's
gonna he's gonna blow my mind with this
[ __ ] education I did my undergrad
here and then I matriculated this is why
these guys I'm a millennial man and
there's an oxymoron and enough
millennial bashing let's get on what is
it Generation Z and based on the
description you gave about the pumpkin
patch moms I didn't think it was bad at
all
simply what has happened is that we are
witnessing the goalposts changing oh
okay the goalpost of [ __ ] has always
changed in history and will continue in
the future all right I'm back on board I
like this guy for example this is
actually brilliant Nick around the
1800's showing a bit of ankle was
considered provocative yeah they get you
drowned as a witch right Jesus Christ
how [ __ ] up was that you know they
would keep drowning you are trying you
know semi drowning you until you
admitted that you were a witch if you
drowned that meant you weren't a witch
and then if you just said all right
[ __ ] I'm a witch then they burned you
so then you were underwater going like
okay well this sucks but at least I'm
not hot
ironically at this time showing your
cleavage or the D call it call attention
o was considered classy oh I get it I
get that I get it what is it decla tosh
what does that mean titties
cuz outta me what a [ __ ] great word
for titties I'm gonna use it this time a
woman has a titty so what are you
looking at yeah I'm looking at your
décolletage whoo I see you have a ring
but is it serious
Oh a neckline oh but that's still good
that's like I'm looking at your neckline
not your teddies huh gently madam I must
say I really admire your breathtaking
decolletage deck Lata I'll never be able
said what's gonna be even worse is that
[ __ ] drunk idiot trying to remember
that word when he stares or somebody
sick that was only date you dead cottage
there all right so it's actually
neckline not cleavage well it depends on
what they considered neckline back there
I don't know here's a quote from a
woman's magazine in the 1800s Jesus guy
actually did research called labelled a
psalm bleh all right
a lady with the well-turned ankles
should never wear her petty court coats
too short so if she sprained her ankle
getting off the horse and her [ __ ]
ankle was too big to stuff into her
infinity button boots she shouldn't show
it is that what they say what does that
mean an eighty a lady with a well-turned
ankle she [ __ ] got crossed over right
know how do you guys know all these
[ __ ] words it's unbelievable
all right anybody should never wear her
petticoats too short
chic cheap exhibition soon sink into
contempt what I think that means
somebody thinks a you want to [ __ ] you
want to [ __ ] it and then you're like no
like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
is that what happens I'm lost I'm lost
in all of that is that amazing that
that's English
and I don't even understand it I am sure
we agree about that a mom showing her
bare ankles is not [ __ ] at all but
simply normally dressed you know this
guy is presenting a wonderful argument
for butt cheeks hanging out of a pair of
daisy dukes you don't think there was a
bit of an overcorrection when you have
to get waxed to go to a [ __ ] pumpkin
patch is there a decolletage word for
your [ __ ] clam I would love to hear
that
another example is e Santa raw 1971
spring haute couture what it would it
flip what is this no Sports Illustrated
swimsuit model forty show in Paris okay
I guess 1971
so where do they do some throwback [ __ ]
like Mitchell and s40 [ __ ] 1971 this is
an example of the goalpost shifting of
what is considered [ __ ] between
generations
what ease and are all presented at that
Fashion Show was a model with a short
green colored chubby fur coat and a
dress that tightly fit the hips with a
line up of strappy velvet platform
sandals the young people at the time
loved the style and it became a
commercial success but the older people
hated it because the style the style
that a general presented was inspired by
prostitutes of the 1940s at Nazi
occupied Paris
during the war what wait but older
people hated it big because the style
that Issei LaRon presented was inspired
by prostitutes of the 1940s at Nazi
occupied Paris during the war well yeah
I mean everybody knows the Nazis had the
best [ __ ] uniforms ever they did they
just [ __ ] they had badass uniforms it
even influenced the horse so they were
just like well look you know if I'm
going to a Texas Jean I need to dress a
little bit you know but since the young
people were too young to remember even
care
issei laurent new style remained popular
for an entire decade but i get it bill I
am sure when I'm old I will be
complaining about whatever the new goal
posts that is set maybe the new goal
post will be topless moms at the pumpkin
patch with their hoo-ha bare and I'm not
gonna lie that would probably upset me
too
alright I understand what he's saying I
try not to be that older guy but come on
man when you got like your sex Goods out
you know I mean I mean I you know the
thighs showing I don't give a [ __ ] you
know you got shorts on whatever that's
you know but when your butt cheeks all
right you know Plus let's just is it
there a time and place for that this
[ __ ] kids there you got your ass out
guys are trying to pay attention so the
kids don't get kidnapped you're doing a
misdirection with your [ __ ] buns over
here this is how kids go missing it
isn't there a certain insecurity level
there like this is supposed to be all
about the kids God for [ __ ] bid they
have their forty five [ __ ] minutes in
a pumpkin patch you have to steal focus
with your tits and ass out I don't think
I'm wrong on this one I agree with what
this guy's saying like style definitely
change like I didn't think that there
would be any news
then I would be going out at isn't music
after Ozzy fit the [ __ ] head off a
bat you know that along came people like
just [ __ ] pushing buttons on a laptop
and I'm just like wait a minute that's
not [ __ ] music you don't have to do
you have to learn how to number trying
to play a guitar like a [ __ ] C chord
what's the worst can't [ __ ] back in
black you put it down to see who can't
[ __ ] type these days everybody
[ __ ] type goddamn secretary
give me a [ __ ] arena act baby baby
baby and whatever that [ __ ] thing as
they play on everything yo Billy tickle
toes pollution no Jesus yo Billy tickle
toes I certainly produced trash like
everyone else but I feel like I have a
relatively small footprint do you see
what Instagram is done for people we're
talking about pollution and they're
making it all about themselves I
certainly produce trash like everyone
else but I feel alright no shock that
the media focuses on how much the
average guy sucks cuz they're owned by
the same guy whose company is dumping
[ __ ] on to dolphins faces see this is
what I have to deal with like I don't
even know what that sentence means
okay I see what you're saying they focus
on the individual rather than all of
these giant companies how much they're
polluting okay I understand that all
right we're on the same page I thought
that that whole carbon credit futures
exchange thing you talked about last
week I just read about it was [ __ ]
conspiracy but it seems to be a real
plan it's [ __ ] up that our economy is
affected by rich people gambling on the
price of what oil would be in the future
carbon must be the the next logical step
evil sucks but this long-term plan evil
is some real frustrating stuff bill oh
thanks for bringing it up again with no
solution I think if in the future what
you want to have is you want to have
solar panels connected to an electric
fence around your house an ar-15
powdered food you know and just somebody
who can put up with you and likes the
same kind of music you do you just stay
in the [ __ ] house that's it's the
only solution I see PS did you know that
the US military causes more pollution
than 140 countries combined no I did not
know that but they don't they also they
drive tanks I mean that's it's a little
worse than a Prius oh I think
did you know that elephants take bigger
shits than you doh I I had a friend in
the air force who was explaining to me
that they do fuel dumps over the ocean
if they don't use all their fuel they
can't justify asking for a higher budget
the next year so they just dump it over
the ocean why can't they fix that why
can't they just give them their [ __ ]
body you know yeah I don't know I don't
understand you know actually you know
I've been telling you guys I've been
studying for this [ __ ] instrument
rating on my pilot's license and so I'm
watching all these aviation videos and
[ __ ] like that I try to stay away from
the ones where people crash but yeah
yeah but that's unfortunately how you
learn there's a lot of well told you
what this guy did so anyways I gotta I'm
gonna post this video this is [ __ ]
video and I didn't know you could do
this but I guess when you're flying
along out there you know when you talk
to the tower or something like that you
can actually ask them what your [ __ ]
ground speed is I don't know why you'd
want to know that maybe if you're trying
to get somewhere you have a ridiculous
head wind which I've been involved in
that there's nothing worse when you
think you're gonna be flying over
traffic and then you have such a brutal
headwind that there's people underneath
you passing you on the [ __ ] highway
like it's sitting there right so this
guy was in some little ass [ __ ]
Cessna and he asked what his ground
speed was so the [ __ ] you know the
air traffic told him it was like [ __ ]
80 knots which is ridiculously low and
it was a stupid thing I guess to ask I
don't understand the etiquette here ok
this is like I guess some aviation you
know don't [ __ ] admire your home run
the next guy's gonna get hit so he asked
what his [ __ ] ground speed was and so
then some other do she was in a twin
just to be a [ __ ] when he called and he
also asked for his ground speed so the
guy told him Baba Baba you're doing 140
knots so it's just something you know
who's got a bigger dick I got more
entrance
I'm going faster than you right so that
just happened to be a Navy pilot in the
area flying like one of those [ __ ]
you know f-18 whatever the [ __ ] they are
so just to be a douche he calls him and
now it is his position then ask for his
ground speed and they go yeah your
ground speeds like 600 [ __ ] 80 knots
right shuts them the [ __ ] down and you
think that's it turns out there was also
a guy crew flying a stealth bomber at 89
thousand feet they were so high up they
were like over Utah could see LA like
they can see the whole [ __ ] coast
doing this loop up to Seattle getting
refilled and I don't know what altitude
they come down to get refilled they
didn't like two and a half hours right
he called in and asked for his [ __ ]
ground speed and they were like [ __ ]
1000 [ __ ] 200 something that's what's
going on up there just to let you know
well you think it's a bunch of eggheads
up there Jay that's your get to the
vector couple Bluff then no different
than that douche in front of you what
the [ __ ] stop like staring at his
phone when it's I'll post that video the
guy who flying the [ __ ] stealth
bomber tells the story the most amazing
thing was they're flying 87,000 feet and
that was to say like he was I don't
where was over Arizona or something like
that and he could see LA he could see
the roundness of the fly they should
take that guy from the [ __ ] NBA and
bring him up in that goddamn thing all
right when you play the Lakers you play
they're up there it's where you the
Seattle SuperSonics used to be you see
how it's disappearing though you see
that you see how it's moving we didn't
paint this on the [ __ ] windshield
um anyways alright NSA turned on my
webcam now Jesus Christ this is this is
a way a tract on this [ __ ] podcast
who is the NSA national security what
agency what art when what are they this
is CIA there's the FBI
what are they oh he was in also like the
guys spying on you in the Kentuckian
computers oh all right and by the way
how is he able just to come back well
what the [ __ ] I mean he was on that
thing for like an hour I watched all
those spy movies and you have to get off
at two four minutes or else they trace
the call we'd have to keep running from
pay phone to pay phone just facetiming
at different pay phones around Russia I
didn't understand how that worked what
is what is the US government just gonna
just let that guy know nobody cares
people care but nobody nobody cares
enough right just let it back it what's
he gonna be sitting in a bar do you know
what they're doing
[Applause]
you know I can't pay off my student
loans dance no more [ __ ] I don't what
am I gonna do about it yeah all right
dear bill hearing your rant on the
October 14th Monday morning podcasts
about privacy made me wonder if you
wanted to hear about my experience with
Big Brother I actually do because I just
so [ __ ] up I have these idiots I
wasn't duane reade the other dick we
have a phone number they like the dead
guys dead dad dad what are you telling
them this [ __ ] for you don't think
that's [ __ ] crazy to just give some
[ __ ] if yeah I don't know why people
[ __ ] do that I don't know why you
become a cashier and check yourself out
and work for [ __ ] free III don't
understand I don't know ok anyway ok few
years ago I was seeing this girl at my
former job the company had a strict no
towns policy against what they called
fraternizing ok when they caught lucky
at work and then make you work 60 hours
where else am I gonna meet somebody but
we were both supervisors of different
areas this sounds like a porno so our
relationship did not violate any rules
even so it's a workplace environment in
a small [ __ ] splat town so that's funny
small [ __ ] splat town so yeah so you
know these bored [ __ ] people ran
their mouths and HR warned the girl I
was seeing about fraternizing and sexual
harassment well how did they know you
were seeing people how didn't you see
they with you was seeing her you [ __ ]
making out with her in the parking lot
slapping her on the ass when she walked
by your cubicle
see you tonight honey
sure your turn to cook no no I just
friends we're just friends
ah alright so it became kind of a
running joke between us like we would
make plans after work and say you got
time for a little franchising later on
[ __ ] like that you know what's the
second they don't work together all the
excitement's of doing something noddies
gonna go away and they're gonna have to
get to know each other as people and the
whole relationships gonna win float so
one afternoon we were hanging at my
place watching a movie on my laptop and
we end up saying screw the movie and had
sex yeah you can't [ __ ] in front of a
flat-screen TV you can't do anything
after she got dressed and left and I
watch it to her car when I came back to
the bedroom I noticed the little green
light next to the webcam on my laptop
was on and even though the screen had
timed out and turned black what happens
next is something I've never told
anybody I sat down on the bed like what
the [ __ ] and before I even touched the
computer screen touch the computer the
screen turned blue and the word
franchisor scrolled diagonally across in
big white letters no I don't believe
this like some [ __ ] Windows 98 I
don't believe it I know you thinking the
girl probably said it as a screensaver
to play a joke on me but she never even
touched it it's a MacBook Pro I don't
even think you can make a shitty
screensaver anyway
I don't even get that joke I'm glad that
was funny anyway I hit the space key and
the screen went back to where you enter
your password I immediately put a piece
of tape over the webcam and the laptop
hasn't done that sense but some creep in
his cubicle definitely watched me bang
that girl thanks and go hug yourself you
filthy animal oh I can see you know some
tech nerd coworker and then he's just
sitting there night after night with his
dick in his hand trying to see he can
hear him [ __ ] well isn't there a way
to then take your computer and then they
can back-trace it can't they [ __ ]
that guy was my favorite guy ever we can
freakin [ __ ] well [ __ ] back traits
this thing I never saw a guy love his
kids so much that he just [ __ ] just
went ballistic like that um can't they
just kind of trace that and then you out
yourself what a [ __ ] dude you want us to
can you understand though how much like
not of a creep that guy let's say this
actually happened and let's say that is
a co-worker do you understand like how
much of a creep has been drawn out of
him because of these [ __ ] things okay
back in the day he would have had to
work for it he would have had to [ __ ]
you know work his way like climbing over
backyard fences doing it at night
fighting off [ __ ] dogs peak in the
[ __ ] window and risk getting caught
now he can just sit here and honestly I
think that that's why that this does
this [ __ ] here like the level of [ __ ]
porn that I have watched
like I find myself now when I why I try
not to watch it anymore I'm trying to
[ __ ] quit that the way put booze III
just like nothing shocks me anymore and
I find myself like not like laughing at
it but laughing like I don't know like
pleasantly like I'm watching the Golden
Girls like just like like I'm watching a
TV show now I definitely rented some
porns back in the [ __ ] day but there
was a shame to it yeah the [ __ ] go
down there and a guy you know I always
had those stupid saloon doors I don't
know why looks like he's not renting the
Bourne Identity right Bourne Identity
wasn't even out there and he's not gonna
be renting was that [ __ ] mermaid
movie splash there you go Andrew
crushing it splash alright anyways
family thinks I should I joined a sex
cult - what the [ __ ] is this alright hey
Billy blow sake
I'm 24 single live alone and my life has
become crazy recently everyone in my
close family thinks I joined a
psychedelic sex cult when I went to New
Zealand this summer while in New Zealand
I met up with a lady who knew where to
pick psychedelic mushrooms I didn't know
about that when I went to New Zealand we
went to her house you don't trip for the
first time in a different country right
that's why he distributes your papers
please
we went to her house where she had four
dairy cows hot chicks always hang out
with fatter girls don't they and picked
mushroom sorry it was an easy joke I
went with it I'm sorry to all the Plus
Size billboard models out there that's
so annoys me now that they put less
pleasant looking people on billboards
now it's like where was that when I was
younger with my blinding torso
okay well we went to her house where she
had four dairy cows and picked mushrooms
out of the cow patties don't need to see
the process cow [ __ ] we washed them off
and then ate them maybe 10 minutes after
picking them you didn't let him sit in
the [ __ ] Sun to get rid of any more
bacteria within 20 minutes I'm losing my
mind
I pretty much start having massive
anxiety attacked she comes to calm me
down she's so damn hot and sitting on my
lap so I start kissing her what this
sounds like a [ __ ] Pink Floyd
animated thing you watch while you're
tripping it one of their things right
one thing turns to another and we [ __ ]
yes I think one thing turns to another
and then you started kissing her you
don't start kissing her she's sitting on
your lap what then turn to another we
did exactly what everybody thought was
gonna happen
one thing turns to another we've just
started baking bread I felt a connection
with my Higher Being and the collective
consciousness with the woman how much
mushrooms is this guy selling right now
there guys do we gotta go to New Zealand
we got to meet some chick who has she's
gotta have four she's gotta have four
cows
craziest experience of my life so far so
far like we were the same being
dissecting each other's bodies okay okay
I don't know why I just pictured like
dragonflies and insects there I don't
like that
all right we started traveling New
Zealand together the next day and two
days after we were at the beach where we
met two guys please don't do mushrooms
with them who tuckus who took us to a
shaman cake man in a cave this is a
trusting person huh all right he reads
our energy and says the usual hippie
[ __ ] like us being old souls and [ __ ] he
gave us both a hit of peyote and blessed
us what is peyote is that just like
steroid weed no I'll constant cactus oh
okay
and we left high as [ __ ] so we ran
around the beach half-naked laughing
because of how perfect everything is
la-dee-da we have a good time and [ __ ]
a lot while on psychedelics I'm you know
I'm beginning to understand why your
parents think you joined a sex color I
come back to the u.s. a couple weeks
later and immediately tell my brother
over the phone my experience I'd been
gone for two and a half months and while
I was gone my brother had a major
lifestyle change and I had no idea he
went with other things he was gay he was
banging all these broads and now all of
a sudden it's got a mustache he's got a
boyfriend he went from being an illest
atheist to on to now a born-again
Christian
uh-huh oh come on Hollywood like you
don't have the [ __ ] answers Jesus
Christ
oh [ __ ] everything man I moved out of my
hometown I know everything and was very
concerned and upset by my experience
it's safe to say that something happened
to these people is kids like this is
really extreme behavior eating mushrooms
out of cow [ __ ] in New Zealand all right
you guys like well that sounds pretty
normal that's funny that really didn't
get a groan but he's a born-again
Christian oh oh my god what happened
[Applause]
anyways he doesn't like what I'm doing
so much so that he tells everyone in our
deeply religious family there it is that
I was initiated into a psychedelic sex
cult and now the devil has my spirit ah
I get it I get it he was the black sheep
and now he became the favorite son and
now you're out there banging broads on
mushrooms and they and they're all
waiting for Jesus to come back and
they're jealous okay I get it
my sister blocked me on everything
brother tries to get me to go to rehab
grandma wants me to get baptized in my
mom cries almost every night worried
about my mental health well you're
eating cow [ __ ]
I'm gonna guess not having you know
having unprotected sex in a different
hemisphere I would be concerned
she does have a right to be concerned
what do you guys think about that
commercial where they have that the moms
of like soldiers and they go yeah well
you know mothers serve - okay all right
I'll give you that one it's like can
they ever hit off the blue tees I told
them that I'm totally fine and
everything has been blown out of
proportion but they think the devil is
making me say those things oh my god the
can you start filming this please this
is like a reality show I loved my family
and don't want to lose contact all right
now it got said but I know they've gone
way too far with this and I'm not really
into their religious outlook and won't
go to church my question is what do I do
about my crazy religious family thinking
I'm into psychedelic sex cults well
maybe stop telling him that's your
[ __ ] broads in New Zealand on [ __ ]
mushrooms I'm not saying to stop doing
that just stop telling your overly
religious family that this is what
you're doing this is one of the easiest
questions ever you can keep your [ __ ]
trap shut thank you for everything you
are and go [ __ ] yourself you [ __ ] all
right let's got a couple more you guys
hanging in there all right all right all
right okay here we go
how come nobody takes me seriously all
right
hey there bill exclamation point
well maybe come on too strong everybody
thinks you're weird
I'm a 23 year 23 year old male I am a
musician and been working retail Bed
Bath and Beyond
I thought retail was close you'd look
lovely in this bathroom for the last
three and a half years lately I've been
pondering heavily on the fact that my
whole life that my whole entire life
nobody has ever taken me seriously I'm a
pretty comical guy I'd say I'm not
saying I cracked the greatest gut
splitting jokes in the West in the West
how adorable he's 23
ANCA do the most gut splitting in the
West I love this guy this guy would
return your wallet hey by the way
somebody hit my car I had it parked in
the parking lot and the [ __ ] wait
till I came down gave me all the [ __ ]
is there's some good people out there
you know they're really a shout out to
that person who I'm gonna pay for
because you were a good guy
anyways but I do have a dry sense of
humor and most of the time joking with
every interaction I'm in I love to laugh
and make people laugh what can I say but
the thing is oh man this guy I don't
know he's either just a [ __ ] great
guy or he's sitting on something and
half the mountains gonna blow off one
day but the thing is I've recapped and
replayed every moment in my head I can
think of where somebody shot down any
idea I had for something oh gosh he
thinks he's gonna have the mohawk any
day he's talking to me you don't respect
my ideas numerous occasions when I've
given a tat I've been given a task at a
job and my peers automatically talk to
me like I'm some kind of [ __ ]
simpleton dude I think you're just too
nice and I think you also say things
like crack the best jokes in the West
and they think that you're a simple
person I think you're really wholesome
person you know it is I
you're not jaded and you're probably
working with a bunch of dicks and they
think they can get over on you so
unfortunately you're gonna have to get a
little dirt on you you're gonna have to
take someone down to the mat you're just
gonna have to or they're not gonna
respect you
and also people often say that they
can't picture me mad I know he's
wholesome or is this the guy in the news
like he was the nicest guy we never we
never saw it coming all of my managers
that all of my jobs have always kind of
picked on me - you're not sticking up
for yourself and I'd be completely
honest I know this is something I've
struggled with my whole life but it's a
little hard to put into words now how
I'm feeling about this yeah dude yeah
you've been picked on and you're one of
those guys rather than being an [ __ ]
- you're trying to like if you I act
this way if I act cool maybe everybody
will be cool and people will stop
[ __ ] with me I did that I tried that
didn't work for me look at the angry
[ __ ] lunatic when I was sitting on
that's true I think I feel that I've set
this expectation for everybody that I'm
always in a positive and jokey move so
whenever I want to be taking seriously I
don't get that in return I yeah I'm
tellin you dude you gotta you gotta
break some eggs here to get the omelet
going I think I'm sure my own just
within the law don't want to send you
down virtually breaks Mitch
not gonna tell you that what this is
being filmed so they said see some what
I'm not a gun guy it was I was trying to
member how do you [ __ ] I'm sure my
own personality has brought this upon
myself I know you haven't actually
really liked guns by the way I just
scared shitless of them because I don't
know what I think about I know you
haven't known me my entire life and now
you know and you hear noise like no
anti-gun you are late at night when you
hear a noise you're like I should have
been a gun guy I'm sure my own
personality has brought this upon myself
I know you haven't known me my entire
life and see how I handle it but just
seeking a little wisdom here I had tried
being shorter with people and just a tad
douchier to see if that would work I did
all of this I've done this I've been
when you're AK and I don't feel that's
an effective method yeah you don't want
to be a [ __ ]
if you have any general advice on this
kind of thing anything would help
love the podcast love you stand up thank
you and go [ __ ] yourself yeah what you
need you know what I would try to do sit
down and just start to write about
yourself don't do it on the internet cuz
someone's gonna find it alright just
write down in a notebook what am I
feeling what do I want what makes me sad
you got to get in touch with what's
going on with you and then I don't know
I don't know I kind of did that a lot of
anger came out and then it overly came
out and then what I would literally
would have to do was when I was calling
somebody up to have a confrontation I
would literally have to write the points
I wanted to make and before I made the
phone call I swear to God I would I drew
a smiley face like don't get angry and I
you know I'm still [ __ ] working on it
so I think what you're working on a lot
of people are going through you're only
23 you know I didn't I didn't learn how
to have a confrontation and stick up
myself well into my early 30s and it's a
great skill to develop you can totally
turn around it's not like you're tone
deaf and then you got to go sing a song
this is just learning how to confront
people just go baby steps
and maybe you know maybe there's
somebody we go buy food and they're a
little little flippant with you no no
don't get arguments in public that's a
bad example sorry I don't know you're a
good guy you know I don't know it just
just I would start with that and then
maybe I would go into therapy and figure
out what's going on with yourself and uh
and just take it from there and just you
know gradually work your way up like
anything else anything else that's it
takes a while to get good at something
so just don't beat yourself up all right
and uh yeah [ __ ] all those people that
that who do that when I see a nice guy
like you who says all of those things
that make people laugh I hope in a good
way that they then go and take advantage
of you all right so here we go all right
smoking habit um by the way that's why I
think every like every kid should learn
like [ __ ] jiu-jitsu so everybody's on
the same no but then the bullies learn
it too yeah stupid idea forget that all
right smoking habit am I supposed to get
out of here did they just shut off the
[ __ ] AC cuz all of a sudden that's
getting hot let's just try to heat him
up sweet all right hey Bill I really
hate myself right now because I smoked a
cigarette I'm a 15 year old is that
young Jesus Christ all the [ __ ]
chicks was smoking her by the time they
were 11 when I was a kid I'd started out
in the beginning of in the year where I
found my parents stashes cigarettes and
I later smoked one a day later he was
purely out of curiosity now it's back on
I busted you
but when I did cough on on the first hit
wait it was purely out of curiosity but
when I did cough on the first hit put
then after I was fine
oh but thank you Jesus how do you figure
that out I did cough on the first hit is
the pee next to the beat it's not even
close alright but then after I was fine
almost like I was a natural looking now
I did this five times between two months
before banning myself from ever doing it
again yeah you don't want to do this
there's no quicker way of ruining your
[ __ ] life than starting to smoke
cigarettes other than I don't guess
smoking [ __ ] opium with somebody
recently however stress and [ __ ] got to
me to smoke another and now I'm scared
of being a smoker I hate myself because
I know smoking is bad for me but I just
love the smell and the buzz from a
cigarette
I gotta admit to this is making me want
to smoke a cigar I do want to stop this
immediately but I know that I'm a really
impulsive guy in pursuing tobacco sounds
like a fun thing to me you're gonna
regret it I regret starting to smoke
cigars I'll tell you that even though I
know it's wrong he says cigars sound
awesome to me and I want to at least
experience the taste of one in my life
so bill how the [ __ ] do I get my brain
off tobacco what is your best way to get
off addictions I have found to not have
it in my house and I could do not bring
the devil into your house how my
drinking went off the rails was I
brought it into the house and then there
was no bartender to shut me off
I could pour the drinks as big as I
wanted I could drink whenever I wanted I
had the free time I would put on me TV I
would watch the Rockford file in a
minute and then another that it was just
[ __ ] awesome now I want to drink
right
so I got the booze out of my house it
takes like it takes a little bit of time
it takes like some distance there's some
stupid formula some stupid [ __ ] like
that I don't know what it is
I've almost gone a year without drinking
and I've had no desire to but when I was
in Asheville North Carolina both nights
when I got off stage there's something
about the south
I [ __ ] love the South I love the pace
I love the whole [ __ ] thing and
there's something about it it's just it
just you know taps into the cigar smoker
in me well I just want to sit down and
both nights I got off stage and I was
just like man I would [ __ ] kill for a
[ __ ] not a small giant glass a
[ __ ] bourbon right now and just sit
down and [ __ ] hang with my friends
and and like so it I don't know that it
ever quite goes away I'm not like an
addict it's funny to hear me tell these
stories but like I am more just like I'm
like a creature a habit so it's a it's a
fascinating thing like addiction and
that type of stuff like you know trying
to eat well it's just like one [ __ ]
trip to McDonald's cuz you like it just
totally it's like you took a hit of the
[ __ ] crack pipe and then all of a
sudden I want I want [ __ ] McDonald's
Egg McMuffin sounds good to me
and in your head like no it doesn't but
the grease is still in your going yeah
do it do it so I think there's some
lingering [ __ ] and you still from that
that the the tobacco and you know when
they do all of that [ __ ] [ __ ] they
heard you know that the dip they put a
little bit of glass in it so [ __ ] you
know microscopic cuts and it goes right
into you get that rush like I've heard
at bars from people who had no [ __ ]
Bachelorette degree have told me that
the food industry was actually jealous
of hard drugs and they wanted what they
called that craveability so they've done
that with their [ __ ] food and they
give all of these people the trumps the
Obamas and all this [ __ ] money so
there they look the other [ __ ] way and
I have no literature to back any of that
up
[Applause]
all right lastly but not leastly I want
to thank all you guys for coming out - I
really appreciate it oh all righty
all right overrated underrated okay
I always said underrated not watching
football you know riding on your bike
while your daughter rides a tricycle in
a circle you know going and making those
[ __ ] bank deposits all that [ __ ] you
would have been done if you weren't
watching like I'm going back to I'm just
picking one good game a week I watched I
watched LSU beat [ __ ] Auburn great
goddamn game and Adam it's in two weeks
I'm hoping when LSU plays you guys I'm
hoping I'm hoping you don't think so
come on shut up dude you guys went on
the [ __ ] time roll Tyrell Ricky are
you from Alabama sir oh oh I didn't hear
you sorry you're in the dark I can't
[ __ ] hear you oh I hate that birthday
on that affecting ma'am you know I don't
give a [ __ ] you know everybody so you're
in the [ __ ] dark I can't see you
there's other people [ __ ] laughing
Jesus Christ you gonna hash tag voice
shamed
[Laughter]
no more live podcast this is a [ __ ]
hour oh all right overrated underrated
you just mad because you get made fun of
by Georgia they do Georgia actually
looks down in Alabama I'm a Taurus you
all look the same to me
all right underneath it that's how it
works it just it kind of goes west the
more further west you are the more you
get [ __ ] on and then it all ends in
Mississippi and everybody just shits on
them I don't understand right overrated
under it okay underrated top today's hot
moms oh the pumpkin patch fun here fan I
should say I remember moms in the 70s
80s and 90s looking all mom like yeah so
do I all right I think we guys and
lesbos have it better I don't even know
what that means
maybe it's cuz I was born in 81 and
everyone look old to me I love seeing
mom stay active and caring for their
health as well as taking care of their
family what does that have to do with
lesbians is that is that because they
could get married now finally they can
adopt a kid so technically one of them's
a mom or they both moms
I don't know how [ __ ] works oh god am
I in trouble now I don't know it's a new
world oh there we go
this way the podcast all the questions
are answered
that would have bumped me for a whole
week what the [ __ ] did that mean alright
last thing here overrated no that's
overrated today's hot mom's it's the
same thing
I appreciate this I appreciate all the
self-care but would would it kill some
of these women to do some mom things
once in a while when it's not convenient
for the camera maybe it's because I was
born in 81 but I remember moms putting
their family first glad you're getting
in some yoga but could you maybe teach
your kids a little something about
anything in your spare time for Christ's
sake
there we go if that attention is going
towards themselves it ain't going
towards their kids yeah it's a weird
[ __ ] time you don't actually thought
the last thing I'll say here is the have
you noticed like when you watch like
youtube videos that kids falling down I
don't know why I got on that thing but
I'm watching it it used to be like
accidental you know what I mean like no
my kid was sitting there laughing and
then fell off the chair was [ __ ] okay
or whatever and it becomes like a funny
thing like a kid falling down but now
I've noticed like when you watch them
because they know they're gonna get big
hits there's plenty of time for the
parent to get over there the kids
walking towards the hot stove Oh what
are you doing what are you doing touch
it touch it what do you do it that gets
a little creepy
alright well that was the live podcast
thank you guys so much for coming out
go [ __ ] yourselves we'll see on the
other one thank you Andres emili´s for
setting up all of this stuff and thank
you to dynasty typewriter with a
wonderful space I'll be in back signing
posters taking pictures kissing babies
whatever thank you goodnight
[Applause]